[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
end game class as always my name is
caleb denby and today i want to take you
guys through
some interesting positions interesting
end games
where one side is fighting for a win
despite material
being totally equal and this includes
some cases where
it's not so obvious that one side even
has
any serious weaknesses in the position
to take care of
but we will see a common theme here
being the theme
of extra space extra space can be a very
valuable tool
of course in middle games making your
opponent feel cramped without having
any room to move his pieces but
oftentimes that scene is being
alleviated when pieces are traded off
the board you know what does it matter
if i have less space
if there aren't enough pieces to make
use of it and so we'll see
in the games i have for you here today
that space can be a very useful tool
even in the end game
uh and we'll see some other examples
where
one side fights for a win despite
material being completely
even so this first game i wanted you
guys to take a look at here
i just found by clicking around it's by
a guy named olivier renee
and i am fortunately going to butcher
the other person's name
uh implying i didn't butcher the first
named
mirai morales it's french i don't speak
french anyways
let's jump into the game see what
happened uh
of course this is not the end game it
was a catalan
opening for those of you who care of
course i don't care because this is
end game class not an
opening class and i wanted to pause here
we are about to
enter the end game uh of course we have
a
reasonably symmetric pawn structure four
versus four on the king's side two
versus two on the queen side
we have one bishop against one bishop
one knight against one knight
and two rooks against two rocks you know
arguably enough pieces on the board
that this is not an endgame but we'll
see that the rooks are very quickly
going to come off the board
and this is the first position where
black
makes a claim that he is fighting for an
advantage
so from this position how can you with
the black pieces
try and already mysteriously fight for
an advantage
out of seemingly nowhere out of a
seemingly dead equal
dead drawn position what do you think
black should do
in this position already anticipating
this bishop and knight against bishop
and knight endgame
what do you guys think in the chat room
i'll give you just a moment
to think about it
just a moment to think about it here
um and while people still are coming
into the show i'm not gonna wait too
long
if you want to try and find the answer
for yourself at home go ahead and pause
it
the idea of course is to play the
interesting move
f5 and i think this would be a move that
a lot of
lower rated players and even myself
would be quite reluctant to play in a
position like this
you know often times in end games you're
taught never to move this f pawn
and here especially it looks like you're
leaving this e pawn sort of in the dust
the idea of course is that f5
gains crucial space for the black pieces
now if you take a look at this knight on
d5 it's going to be a mainstay here it's
going to be very difficult
for white to remove this knight from d5
for example with the move
e4 of course this is also following the
principle
of locking the white pawns onto dark
squares
when both sides have a dark squared
bishop so already from this point
rather than sort of rushing into the end
game with rook takes c1
getting the king to the center with king
f8 these are all fine moves
but f5 is quite accurate just to take
away this space from the white pieces
secure this knight on d5
and begin to play in fact for an
advantage
white in this case does opt to trade the
rooks we see rook c1 rick c1 bishop c1
and now we are officially deep into
the end game here uh
and now white i think actually had the
opportunity
to gain even more space and fight for a
bigger advantage
by immediately playing the move e5
already
after e5 the move e4 is going to be
relatively unstoppable uh you can't
really play e4 yourself
you play something like f3 e4 might come
anyways
and now you'll see even with limited
material on the board
black is clearly the player with
superior minor pieces here
with this knight doing an excellent job
of controlling
all of the holes in the position while
black's bishop can come easily
to f6 and put some pressure on b2
instead black chose another option which
is knight b4
the idea of this move of course is to
plant all of the white pawns onto dark
squares or at least as
or at least as many as possible so
knight b4 and a3
putting more pawns onto dark squares we
see knight back to c6
and white now does get to escape with
this knight out to d3 which
perhaps wouldn't have been possible had
black chosen to play e5
uh now there's nothing too crazy going
on here we see black come to the center
with king f7
white fight for some control over
squares with f3
bishop f6 a natural improving move
bishop d2
king e7 bishop b4 check
and now of course black could consider
taking off this bishop
but this bishop isn't a very useful
piece for uh
for white anyways and so in the game
black found
no reason to do so and played the move
king d8
of course this looks scary at first
glance in light
of the move knight out to c5 but in this
case
the b2 pawn is going to be far more
valuable than either the e6 or the a6
pawn for example if here
already knight takes b4 a takes b4
bishop d4 and this knight is getting
trapped and black is
is just winning knight e6 is a bit
better but after king c8
now black can start to push for a past
pawn on the queen side so
bishop b4 looks scary at first with
knight c5 coming but
in the end it's not going to be too bad
for black king f2 was played instead
white correctly calculating that knight
c5 was not going to be good
giving up this pawn and now i want you
guys
to find black's next move here i'll give
you a hint
it's more space gaining it's all about
gaining space in this end game that's
how he fights
for the victory so i will give you a
little bit of time here to try and find
black's next idea
how to continue gaining space
i'll give you just a few more moments
we're working with some
delay here tonight and people are still
on the way in
oh nope my chat room was just not
working
i was feeling so lonely there i was
seeing no no chat but everybody
everybody is chatting my goodness
everybody is chatting all right
so uh i'm seeing a lot of g5s a lot of
h5s
these aren't bad ideas
not seeing a lot of the correct move
though i'm seeing a little bit of course
uh as people in the chat room some
people are saying
a5 is actually the the critical move
here
and the reason for that is while g5 and
h5 are space gaining moves you know
there's there's sort of no denying that
they're not even bad moves at all
uh they aren't fixing weaknesses for
white
whereas the move a5 immediately followed
by the move a4
is permanently leaving this pawn back
here on b2
a square where it can very easily be
targeted by this black bishop
and we can imagine on some sunny day a
knight landing on c4
pressuring both of these white pawns so
always be on the lookout for
opportunities
to fix your opponent's pawn structure in
an unfavorable way in a way
where you can tell they're going to have
to be defending weaknesses
throughout the game and in fact because
of this idea perhaps it would have been
a lot better for
white to consider playing something else
just for example the move b3 would have
been
a pretty reasonable idea for white to
fight against a5a4
and start trying to solve many of his
dark squared problems by just removing
some extra pawns on the queen side white
though not aware of the danger just
plays king f2
and black immediately responds with a5
bishop c5
and a4 now this b2 pawn you're gonna
have to work pretty
darn hard to get rid of it notably if
bishop c3
of course white would be interested in
trading these two bishops
but not under these circumstances
of course now both of these pawns are
going to be rather weak
and black or white is going to have a
difficult job of controlling everything
for example
knight still is coming to c4
after something like king c7 and king d6
so bishop c5 instead and now a4
white brings the king out with e3
and with his extra space black now has
absolutely
no issues in this end game white is
going to struggle to find active play
because he's always going to have to
keep control of the b2 pawn
and black can sort of improve at his
leisure once again
so king c7 was his choice just bring the
king up the board
king d2 and now knight e5 uh of course
white is not really going to find any
solace in the pure bishop end game when
this pawn on b2
is set to be a permanent weakness
white tries to keep more pieces on the
board with king to c2
or perhaps trying to get into this end
game under slightly more favorable
circumstances
if knight takes d3 for example e takes
d3
and coming back to b4 and while this end
game does look pleasant
for black after king d5 for example it's
not going to be the easiest thing in the
world
to invade here for example after bishop
d3 bishop c3
white is starting to build sort of a
wall to keep black
out of the game in the game
black plays the move king c6 just
keeping pieces on the board
bishop bishop e3 is played by white
and now we see g6 just solidifying the
structure
bishop back to d2 and now knight up to
c4
okay bishop to c1 to defend the b pawn
and now i would like you guys to
try and come up with some potential
ideas to keep in mind
for black going forward i'm going to ask
you to pause here
and sort of use our visualization
use our calculation skills and try to
come up
with some kind of active plan for black
in the future
any kind of active plan to fight against
the white structure here
how can we ever win this chess game
because clearly the b2 weakness well you
know it's great for us we can pat
ourselves on the back we made a weakness
here
white is defending it three times and we
can really only attack it with two
pieces so
best of luck trying to get rid of that
guy best of luck to you
get the king up easier said than done
chess king easier said than done
oh he is giving some moves as well with
e5 e4
ideas
so who knows what the first thing we
should do is
what's the first thing we should do
in any end game like this there's
something you should be thinking about
first
so the first thing you should do is
eliminate counter play
right you want to eliminate any ideas
for your opponent
so then you can sort of take your time
improving your position so the first
thing
black does is make sure that the move b3
is never going to come on the board
how does he do that well he does that
with the move knight a5 after h3
knight b3 right bishop e3
and now from here the second thing we
should do is
as some people in the chat are saying we
should just start trying to gain some
more space we should
start trying to apply more pressure to
the white pawns
with as chess king is saying some
threats to create a past pawn somewhere
along the way
as always in these sort of minor piece
end games the way to win
is to get a past pawn or create threats
of getting a past pawn
and use that to either win material or
divert your opponent's pieces
to somewhere they definitely don't want
to be so that your pieces
can get more active so how do we ever
try and make a past pawn here well
uh we just start pushing all our guys
it's as simple as that
we push all of these guys up the board
and then
white's pawns will be under a bit of
pressure there's to be threats of f4
going to be threats of e4 gonna be
threats of h4
and even threats of g4 sometimes
depending on the positions
so by pushing these pawns up the board
black is able to sort of initiate
just some ideas you know he's not
necessarily going to play e4
now he's not necessarily going to play
e410 moves from now
but uh the point is
white is going to have to be calculating
it on every turn
and that's the way you can apply some
practical pressure as well as just
objective pressure in the position where
white is going to have to be very
careful
on every turn and if white slips up just
once then black
might be able to take that opportunity
to convert into a full point
so first and foremost black spent a
couple more moves just
uh shuffling the pieces we have king d5
check king d6 so
getting the king one file closer to the
action
knight d3 and then as some people in the
chat did mention he starts with e5
gaining this amount of space does this
mean he's playing e4 right away
definitely not he's just giving himself
the option to play the move e4
we have knight c1 this knight steps back
to c5 momentarily
again trading off one set of minor
pieces isn't really going to help
white in this case we see knight a2
and then black actually makes the
interesting choice to go
knight e6 and i'm not sure i'm in love
with this choice to be honest with you
um the point is after the move b3
black can immediately get counter play
with the idea of
f4 and while this is true for example
takes takes
bishop back to f2 there's now ideas of
bringing the knight to g5
and an imbalance in the structure i
still am not sure
if i'm in love with white getting rid of
this b2 weakness
in the game though it worked out for him
white i guess was afraid
of these ideas and went with knight c3
instead
pressuring b5 king c6 and then king d3
now of course black is in no rush to
play any
major pawn breaks so he just continues
gaining space with the move h5
knight d1 is played in the game and now
we see black
improve the bishop as well going to e7
and then stepping out
to d6 and now notably here
with the move bishop to d2
white has already made a crucial mistake
so see if you guys can find the tactic
here black to move
and get a winning advantage in this game
black can
already just achieve a completely
winning advantage
from this position after the move bishop
d2
in the game black missed it but of
course
all the pressure is on white here right
if black misses a win
well then black missed a win and he'll
just wait another 20 moves for white to
blunder another win
uh whereas white of course
you know any mistake could be fatal
so you guys are along the right ideas
here knight c5 check and you'll see that
the king is starting to run out of
squares only
these three available to him is there
any way
we could make better use of the lack of
squares for the king
and see a root admin actually has the
right idea here
the winning tactic is the move e4 check
and now uh the funniest end of the game
would of course be king to e3
when bishop c5 is not just check but in
fact
check mate with this king having nowhere
to go
all of his escape scores totally blocked
the king steps back to c2
of course knight d4 is a check and will
pick up a pawn
either on e2 or f3 if king if the king
steps to c3
well then after bishop b2 or bishop f6
check you have many of the same problems
king d4 for example king c2 still runs
into knight d4
king b4 for example and then knight d4
and once again
uh not only uh is the king's side
falling for white
but there's still checkmating threats in
the air right still
some crazy checkmating threats in the
air as well
um so e4 would have won the game if f
takes c4 then of course knight c5 check
king d4 knight takes e4 and this is the
best try
for white although with this knight on
e4 now
pressure on g3 pressure on e2 to come as
well
black is just going to be winning here
bishop e1 for example to guard this guy
we see a check knight g5
and this end game is it's just going to
be hopeless tough
to stop these types of ideas sorry
cannot draw arrows here we go
those three moves we worked hard to get
those arrows on the board hopefully you
enjoy them
this should be five as well and there's
just too many threats on either side of
the board
for white to contend with so e4 would
have been a nice find by black
but as i said uh don't worry too much
about
missing wins in this type of end game
your chance is more often than not
going to come around again right it's
very difficult to play with so little
space
and so many different ideas to calculate
on each move
you know all four of these moves are
ideas for black that white has to keep
in check
and so calculating these on every turn
is is not an easy task so it's no
surprise that white missed this e4 idea
and black you know feeling no pressure
missed it as well
uh bishop d6 was played instead which is
just a natural developing
uh a natural improving move to pressure
on g3
and white now perhaps noticing his his
mistake
makes another mistake in kind with the
move e4
perhaps better for white would be to try
something like knight
to c3 uh defending the e4
square in this manner instead after e4
black to move and get a winning
advantage once again
what do you guys think
okay there's some ideas knight g5 knight
c5 this one is not
as surface level so take a second try
and really find
the winning idea here for for black
you should be able to calculate almost
to the win of material
in this case
almost all the way to the wind of
material
so there's a lot of good ideas in chat
and the correct idea has been mentioned
but again i i think this is the type of
position where
you don't just need the correct idea you
need to be able to uh
to go a bit deeper and find out
if you're actually winning anything in
the position
all right for the sake of time i am
going to move on and show the answer
but if you guys at home really do want
to get the most out of this position i
would suggest you pause the video here
and try and calculate because the line
is actually going to be relatively
forced here from here on out
try and calculate until you think you're
you're just in a clearly winning
position alright
with all that said the best move is in
fact f4 uh and for the reasons that the
people in the chat have given
it fixes these pawns on light squares
and very very importantly
it interferes with the bishop's control
of g5
what does this mean well it means that
knight g5 is now going to be a pretty
devastating threat
white tried pretty much the only thing
that he can try in the position which is
to take on f4
take on f4 and go king e2 now of course
if you went knight g5 you would be met
with the move knight f2
when white is barely covering everything
and this wouldn't be enough to win for
black in fact so if you got to knight g5
you didn't quite get far enough but
after king e2 uh black of course has
better options
than to go knight g5 and in fact best
here for black
is knight d4 check this king now has to
make a decision
queen side or king's side uh in the game
white chose king's side which is of
course you know very natural
and now after bishop e5 white or black
is doing this and this and the pressure
on
f3 is not going away in the game
bishop c3 was played but really white
could play anything here and black's
ideas
is going to be the same which is why i
wanted you guys to try and calculate a
little bit further so if you saw this
idea
of the black king invading then i think
you made it far enough in your
calculations
for you to sort of succeed in a real
game
if you didn't see this idea of invading
with the king then
in your real game i hope you would try
and think a bit longer before committing
to f4
because if you don't see this idea then
it might be rather difficult
to uh to go about winning this game
still anyways in the game bishop c3 and
black just advances the king
we see bishop takes d4 bishop takes d4
check and now king c4
king d2 and king b3 and this
is going to be a tough one now for white
white tries to move king to d3
and let me ask you guys should you take
on b2 or should you play bishop e5 what
should you do
what to do
so patrick has the right answer you guys
are starting to catch on here
of course the answer is you should
calculate bishop takes b2
but if you have any doubt in your mind
any doubt in your mind that you're not
queening first then don't take that pawn
don't take that pawn poliba should be
five your position is great it's gotta
be winning
if you take the pawn and you happen to
be wrong then you are
in for quite the embarrassing game uh it
does turn out that bishop takes b2
is actually a draw so hopefully you guys
calculated it a little bit
found something you didn't like maybe
and decided on bishop e5
so bishop b5 played in the game king
back to d2 and
now of course simply g5 you know no need
to go in
for this end game when you can improve
your position further
uh king c1 was played and now
the ideas for black are sort of all over
the board and in fact
all of them sort of win here of course
as
always black wins this game by creating
past pawns why is it black who ends up
winning
well for one the bishop is better at
stopping it past
stopping past pawns but two in
end games another really important
feature of having extra space
is that your pawns are closer to
queening so you do tend to be the one
winning all of the pawn races just
because your pawns
already have that head start in the game
black started with b4 which is perfectly
fine a takes b4
and now black does end up winning i
believe if you play king takes b4
but much much much more accurate is to
understand that this pawn is going
nowhere
and to win the game you only need to
make two past pawns
so g4 instead is the accurate way to win
the game
hg sorry fg hg
hg and now after f3 uh
king d2 bishop takes b2 the king and the
knight are stretched
too thin to stop both the f pawn and the
h pawn
and black wins the game we see knight b2
king b2
and then i have a question for you guys
do you actually win after b5
or did black make a horrible horrible
horrible horrible horrible mistake
not realizing that white was queening
with check perhaps
do you actually win this chess game with
b5
so everybody says win but nobody knows
why
which is fair you can sort of just
assume a win because these are decent
chess players
great wolf thinks so f2 first so yes not
just
f2 but you do win this game by queening
your f pawn
and the reason is it draws the king to
the first rank
when then you queen with check and are
just in time to stop the b
pawn so a3 drawing the game f2
winning the game king e2 is forced b6
you just queen
queens takes a3 b6 a2
b7 a1 queen check
and now of course black
is just picking up this pawn uh by force
and winning the game
so i really liked this game by black
here you know from the initial position
that we started with
i feel like this move f5 might not be on
the radar
for a lot of people remember we started
all the way back here in what looks to
be just
a dead drawn position maybe you prefer
black a little bit because you
understand that this bishop is better
than this bishop
but definitely very very very very
slight edge if any at
all and then after this move f5 we saw
black slowly increase the
v the advantage gaining space on the
queen side with a5 a4
gaining space on the king side with h5
g6 and e5 and then with all of the
threats in the position
white eventually caved allowing f4 and
allowing black to win
and that is a fantastic way to fight for
the win in these
seemingly boring end games taking space
is a powerful tool in end games just to
recap we had of course the trade of all
the rooks
knight b4 by black to draw the pawn to
a3
and then this mistake by white
allowing the move a5 and a4
and now with b2 fixed as a weakness
black created weaknesses on the other
side of the board
by advancing his pawns taking more space
and then white was stretched too thin
and won the game we saw of course
the king advancing e5 and
h5 as well and then white
simply fell apart
just fell apart after f4 with
victory all right any questions on this
end game before we
move on could white draw with perfect
play depends on where you ask
certainly from the position after f5
this this position should be a draw
white shouldn't lose this uh where did
it all go wrong
it's a little bit unclear
it's a little bit unclear let's say
let's say white played the move b3 here
i think if white plays the move b3
he has a very decent chance of drawing
this this end game
for example if black tries to play a5
now
simply bishop c5 and a4 is going to come
white is fixing his major weakness on b2
and probably shouldn't lose the game but
even after that
i mean it's it's tough to say if white
plays stuff like bishop d4
there's there's some ideas of trying to
liquidate material
that perhaps white missed and even in
this position
perhaps if white played perfectly
responded to
every threat that black made with
precision
then the game might be a draw i don't
know that for effect
but practically white is never going to
play this position perfectly
there's too much to worry about e4 f4 h4
b4
threats to b2 various sacrifices
there's just too much for white to keep
track of on every single turn
and i think practically you can assume
this game is is lost for white
after knight b3 of course there are some
chances for white to
you know have sort of counter tactics to
to liquidate or equalize
but assuming reasonable play i think
black wins this game more often than he
draws
uh good question though
why e takes f4 not knight takes f4 let's
take a look
that knight takes f4 well after knight
takes f4 we take
and then you can't target these guys
your bishop doesn't move like that
your bishop does not move like that
very unfortunate that it does not but it
just doesn't
in fact i think i might prefer white
here king d4
scary stuff scary scary stuff
at one point white black wanted to print
b3
and so yeah if you take here and go b3
i think the issue is the king is is
getting a bit too close it's getting a
bit too close tactically it shouldn't
work out
for example takes takes king d2 there's
always this check
and the king is is going to invade yeah
so you need this bishop to keep the king
out of the game unfortunately after
knight c5
and here i think again maybe b3 could
have been played i mentioned though
black has this idea of playing f4
but it's a little bit unclear to me a
little bit unclear
all right good questions let's go ahead
and
move along
let's just move along here we have
another game that i want to go
over if you watch the previous lecture
of course you saw a nice win
by viktor korchnoy and he is going to
make another appearance here in the end
game class
but this one he ends up being on the
losing side of so we'll see how
robert wade uh managed to fight against
victor korchnoy
and an interesting end game uh to in
fact kind of turn things around
and go on to win let's just jump right
into it
we've got of course the opening play
nobody cares
why would i care about this and oop okay
king e2
rook d8 and i think it's safe to say
we are in fact arriving at an end game
here
so rook uh g to d1 was played
and rook d7 rook d3 and we have
ourselves
a major piece end game black of course
uh with two rooks and a queen white with
two rooks and a queen
and some of you might disagree with me
and say that this is still a middle game
but i think it's fair to call it an end
game with just three pieces on the board
so what do we think about this end game
who is to be preferred here
is white to be preferred or is black to
be preferred
and why what are your initial
impressive impressions chat room then
we'll see
if my evaluation lines up with yours and
for what reasons
we'll see how the evaluations line up
so ariane says he prefers white because
he has more space
anime guy reviews also says whites
i assume for for similar reasons and
it's true
it's very true look at all this space
white has
how can you not love having extra space
white has a target on c7
patrick says that the only thing that
matters in major psn games is king's
safety well
he's heard that not that it's true and
he feels
that white's king is somehow safer
so in this case it is actually going to
be
black who is preferred which might be
counter-intuitive seeing as how white
won the game and this lecture so far has
been about
utilizing extra space so why is black
going to be better
well uh patrick was close to the right
idea where he was saying king safety is
really important in these
end games uh
although patrick thought the white king
was safer it does turn out that
the black king is is going to be safer
back on the king's side
with his pawn shield sort of intact
meanwhile the slightly unexpected break
for black
to prove he is better comes on the board
here with the move f5
and after f5 it does become a little bit
more clear to see
why black is to be preferred because
with the f file opening up
white is going to have very major issues
on the f2 square
as well as the f3 square and his king is
going to be
under a little bit of pressure so white
played rook a3 in the game which is fine
you see takes e4 takes c4 and then
quartz noise simply plays the move
rook to f8 stopping rook a8 check and
preparing to double up
perhaps here though quartz joy missed
his chance to be a bit better with the
move queen to f8
immediately applying this pressure and
not allowing white the time he needs to
necessarily
regroup this might force white into
playing a move like f3 which we'll see
doesn't actually want to do
because it does not allow white's idea
in the game
of after rook f8 of bringing this rook
over to f3
to trade off some pieces and make his
lack of king safety
a little bit less uh important so rook c
to c3
rook d to f7 and now rook f3 and now
finally i will agree with you guys i
think
it is white who should be preferred
thanks to his extra space
so just wanted to point this out king
safety
is very very very important in major
piece end games
especially with more than one major
piece left on the board
and here korchnoy was actually on the
better side of it thanks to his pawn
shield in front of the king
while white's white's king was very
easily opened up
by this idea of f5 courtroy though not
taking the most accurate approach and
white
seizes the opportunity to trade off some
of the rooks
while he still can h5 which chord show
his choice
to give his king left and take some
space on the king's side for himself
we have rook takes f7 rook f7 rook f3
rook f3 king of three and now king h7
and now once again uh white has sort of
solved all of his problems
by initiating this trade of all of the
rooks
but there is still the issue of trying
to
actually win this chess game so with the
white pieces here i want you to try and
imagine
just imagine a world where you end up
winning this chess game
and so we'll see what you guys come up
with in the chat and then i'll tell you
a little bit about how
how you can you can try and arrive at
some winning ideas
what kind of process you can go through
to come up with some winning ideas
so uh professor i assume
l-axis is a very interesting idea he
says f4
would open the center and create a past
e pawn
and this is along the right track right
now f4 looks absurd
right like how are you ever going to
play f4 here even if both your king
and queen support it then e takes f4
doesn't seem bad i mean black can play
something like g5 if he really needs to
but uh it's one of the ideas
to keep in mind here and
not only should you be thinking about f4
in the queen and pawn
end game but you should be thinking
about always
in end games with only one piece left on
the board what happens if this guy gets
traded for this guy if they just
disappear from the board this queen goes
way over there
this queen goes way over there what
happens
who is better and why and
with queens off the board the idea of f4
might become
even stronger with this e-pawn than
being relatively uncontested
and the black king going to divert
itself to defending against this e-pawn
pushing
so f4 a very important idea to keep in
mind
all of a sudden in a position where we
have no idea what we're doing
we suddenly have imagined a world where
we potentially win the game
you know if we get these two pieces off
the board and play f4
this is very much a winning idea a
winning try
uh are there any other
winning ideas that we can sort of
conceive conceive of here
what winning ideas can at least be
thought of
in the position does anybody have any
other ones
any other winning ideas perhaps
so king safety is is not really going to
be as major of
an issue anymore of course it still
matters somewhat with queens on the
board
but in this case the king's safety
matters more uh for the king getting
checked around the queen can sort of
check the king to get to better squares
whereas the ideas of checkmate are sort
of sort of missing right
black's not going to get check made on
h7 white's not going to get checkmated
on f3
barring some kind of you know horrible
horrible mishap where like
okay you can imagine queen f3 queen d7
queen e3 gets played
but white is likely not going to get
checkmated with any sort of reasonable
play
so uh i think the idea of activating the
queen
should be apparent to most people uh i
think the way i phrase the question
sort of leads you to uh to not
necessarily think of this
but yeah activating the queen is is
going to be a good idea if we imagine
uh necessarily not necessarily you know
uh immediately but in a world we land
this queen
f5 we land this queen on g5 we even land
this queen somewhere like f7 d7
we would be attacking a lot of
weaknesses for black right even on e7 we
hit e5 c7 g7
h5 and we know we have some winning
ideas in the king and pawn end game
so because we can sort of offer the
trait of queens
and leverage that uh with the fact that
the king and pawn end game
should be good for us in many cases we
should be able to get our queen to some
of these really really active squares
and start attacking a lot of these
weaknesses that black has made
so anticipating all this white starts
with king e2 which of course
doesn't seem like the most natural way
to try to win the game
but he's just removing the queen giving
the queen more access
to the king side
h4 is played by black seizing even more
space although perhaps this is
pushing this pawn a bit too far queen c3
now
keeps an eye on black's activity as well
as preparing to step to the other side
of the board
queen e7 is black's choice keeping
everything under control
and after queen f3 g6 keeps the queen
out of
f5 queen g4 king g7 white now uses the
fact that he
the king and pawn in games are likely
good for him to play the move queen e6
uh and in fact queen takes e6 i believe
is going to be a losing position here
for
black if you take this d takes
king f6 um and yeah i think king f3
should be good enough
here king g4 well actually maybe
starting with a4 is better but now king
g4 is fine and you pick up these pawns
on the king's side
you still have this idea of f4 to follow
and white should be able to make a past
pawn in the center or on the king's side
and use that to win the game
over on the queen side of the board i
don't want to analyze this
too in depth because it's not the main
point the main point is
clearly white has white is the only one
with winning chances in this end game
and so black is reluctant to trade the
queens right
and because we came up with these
winning ideas of f4
of taking these pawns with the king we
were able to leverage the fact
that the queen trade is good for white
in order to improve our queen's position
and start getting at these weaknesses in
black's camp and that's how white
ended up trying to win this game against
relatively even material
well actually just directly even
material
it turns out the only way to try to save
this game for black was to play this
weird looking move queen g5
rather than queen f6 which was played in
the game and here after queen d7 check
king h6 we don't necessarily have time
to come and take this pawn on c7
because we're going to get checked
checked out of our minds here
right i'm going to get checked out of
our minds we try to run away
then queen c1 check might be a little
bit nasty king d1 for example
check king c1 check you can see two
we take z4 check and you might have
wished you didn't step to the c2 square
after all
but queen g5 was missed by black and of
course
after queen g5 white doesn't necessarily
have to go in for all this he can sort
of reset with something like queen h3
and uh sort of start the game fresh
right just bring the queen back to f3
and start fighting anew in the game
though queen f6 was played
and here robert wade makes an
interesting decision i think
queen d7 check was just objectively a
better version of the end game he got
after queen d7 black really should play
the move queen f7
to defend c7 and then you can get the
king on f7
but robert wade just takes here
immediately and draws the king to f6
alright we're just gonna gloss over that
point think queen d7 was just
objectively better in every way
but he takes on f6 instead and we see
king takes f6
uh so now we have arrived at our king
and pawn
end game right and we noticed one idea
of
f4 but actually we're going to find out
that this one idea of f4
is not going to be enough
for victory in this case the idea of f4
is actually going to be adequately
prevented by black in most cases
so see if you guys can envision
another way to break through if you guys
caught last week's lecture
we did a ton of tactics that involved
breaking through an opponent's pawn
structure
in order to give you a past pawn that
can queen and win the game
so let's see if you guys were paying
attention can you imagine
ever breaking through black structure
and creating a past pawn aside from f4
f4 is the more obvious one
so yeah there there are various moves
that improve white's position h3 locks
the h4 pawn
controls g4 king f3 of course is good
but it'll
be met with king g5 i'm asking if you
can find
some way to break through and create a
past pawn
aside from f4 because f4 you might not
be able to force through
so ariane
and patrick and i think a few other
people are on
the right idea you can imagine a world
right i'm not saying this world you can
imagine a world
where somehow white breaks through
against
these three pawns using these three
pawns right
and i'm not going to spoil it for
anybody watching the video but
try and find this idea if you haven't
already of a way why could potentially
create a past pawn
against this structure it's it's a
really fun one
and we'll see it actually gets played in
the game so king f3 is how white started
but king g5
is the reason why this isn't just very
simply winning black is able to
guard all three of these squares making
f4 not as easy to achieve
and then white plays this move king e3
which is perfectly fine
now if king g4
we do see white wins with the idea of f3
if king h3 then f4 is going to be
winning the game
but in fact after king e3 perhaps a
better try for black would have been the
move b5
playing against the exact idea that i is
going to be introduced later
uh and after b5 maybe white is still
doing quite well with the move a3
when the ideas of f4 are going to be
still in the position
king g4 was played instead f3 check and
then realizing king h3 loses
uh hold on a second this is not
this is not the game this is not the
game disaster
lee chess has messed up my notations
okay
so king e3 was played king g4
was in fact played
and then sorry yeah my notations are
messed up all right
let me do this sorry for spoilers okay
i've got the game back now sometimes
leaches does this unfortunate thing
where when you close and open a study
it makes a different line the main line
than the actual main line
and that's what happened to me so after
king g5 i'm sorry king e3 was
not played in fact a4 was played by
white and now black is forced to pass
with king h5
and now after b4 black actually misses
his chance
to draw the game so black to move
and draw for those of you watching at
home
black had a chance to draw the game here
black had a chance to draw the game and
he threw it all away
threw it all away of course the best
move here
is the stunner b5 sacrificing the b-pawn
for free
for absolutely free with the idea
that after a takes b b6 white can no
longer
make a past pawn using these three pawns
they are locked forever
and the play will be decided by the
king's side
when in fact it is going to be a draw h3
g5 king g2 g4
and f4 is actually important for white
to find
gf3 is forced king f3 and now of course
this end game
is going to be a draw after king g5 no
entry here black can
always guard against it and similarly
black is never getting to f4
because white repeats along e3 and f3
and so the game would have been a draw
if black had found
the stunner b5 perhaps a little
nonchalantly though coach noy plays the
move
king to g5 and now of course what is the
winning move
for white you don't play a5 allowing b5
you play b5 yourself and now after king
h5
the final move again of the game is a5
when black was forced to resign this
is the stunning breakthrough that robert
wade found in the game
that put korchnoy uh i guess in the
ground that's a brutal metaphor that i
didn't really mean to use
but put him in the ground um a5 b takes
a5
b6 and now the c pawn is forced to make
a decision either c takes b6
or c6 either way d6 wins i guess you can
also take here but
d6 and d7 d8 is tough
to stop notably in this position
black is in a highly unfortunate
situation
where he has to decide between king f6
and king h5
if for in some alternate universe he got
this position with white to move now a5
in fact would not be winning
because the black king would be just in
time to stop this pawn
of course though you know white would
still win there with the move
uh the tempo on h3 but
none of that in the game kings on age
five cannot catch the d
pawn and robert wade goes home
the victor so uh hopefully you guys
enjoyed these two end games for you here
tonight
both of them of course in games where
there was even material
but one side had a little bit of a space
advantage
and in both games that space advantage
translated into a full point
in the first game because there were so
many weaknesses
locked behind locked in such a small
amount of space
and in the second game more so because
of these tactics
where the advanced pawns are closer to
queening it gives one side all of these
ideas of sacrificing pawns to break
through
with just one because that pawn is going
to be faster
than all of the other pawns which this
idea shows up in both games actually
once again i i hope you guys enjoyed the
endgame class here today
we are going to be continuing live on
twitch with analyze your games right
after this
but if you're watching the video version
thank you so much for watching as always
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you
next time
[Music]
you